how's Gomes man today we're gonna do
something a little bit different we are
going to draw on the iPad I'm gonna
tweet you Bros what to draw and I'll
just follow your instructions
jacksepticeye has a funny series of this
going already I'm not trying to steal
his idea a little link to him if you
wanna check out I'm going through your
suggestions and holy [ __ ] you bros are
[ __ ] up for a suggestion
Shrek's penis is I'm drawing on the iPad
so pardon me if it's not perfect you
listen what's the problem baby what's
your problem I don't know now maybe I'm
an ogre it's just eating there okay done
please wait
Picasso you better watch out is this
video we're gonna get flagged now god
damnit next drawing a very highly
suggested one is Kim Kardashian so here
we go the thing is even if I tried to
draw her well she would still look ugly
as [ __ ]
like I can't draw signs are like pretty
nice I would say so she has a quad but
apparently okay I don't know what
happened with her a lot of people don't
realize this but she actually has two
buds they want to be free but she kept
them in prisons and slaved for years
everyone knows this that one wasn't that
great but next artwork me as a girl
okay spoilers I'll be fabulous alright
let's just draw me I'm like hey yeah and
then we have to do some details alright
it's done what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
and get her with your booty I can do
that
every go I'm crying over it this will go
and you see em in a couple years
learning more about it it's surprisingly
small on Edgar's body I don't know how
how that works but there it is
next one Katy Perry as a dolphin what
the [ __ ] this is a really ugly doll oh
my god alright I'll redo this one cuz
it's awful
oh my god what is this abomination gel
it I don't know how she started her
singing career coming from the ocean but
I think we have some pretty solid elf
evidence here that Katy Perry is not
only a dolphin but she's still if you
look closely here in the cleavage she's
part of the Illuminati but none other
nice a fabulous photo
let's do next one next suggestion
molester moon okay I don't know what the
[ __ ] happened there
all right that's the best I can do
let's just move on next one is easy a
perfect circle goddamn it yourself as a
hentai octopus Wow great suggestions me
as an octopus let's just do that you
sick sick gross I mean we got a good
pace going here I would say God has
forsaken us what is this atrocity
oh my god okay my pretty nice I can see
this in your museum I don't know why you
breath I would give this up probably a
million out of ten okay next suggestion
honey Boo Boo's mom they should be good
such beauty where do you begin she has
this kind of weird thing where she has a
face on top of her face I don't know how
you do that believe it or not we need
more chance more Chin's more Chin's more
Chin's I want Chin's on top of the chins
more Chin's her Chin's will destroy the
galaxy one day the prophecy apps
foretold it alright son this is it
pretty hot okay last one a unicorn with
boobs because that's the best
suggestions I got from Hebrews I'm
serious I don't know what's wrong with
you bros but I guess wrong attracts
wrong people so luckily I find this
tutorial on how to draw a horse
hopefully that'll help
so far so good very nice very nice
all right for the final step I got
damage
I've been correct all right well it was
a unicorn with boobs wasn't it so that's
what I'm gonna do this videos gonna get
flag now great I must have missed a step
somewhere I don't understand there we go
let me just sign this last one
bravissimo
if you want to win any of these go ahead
and leave a like and a comment and I'll
I'll send out a printed version for you
I hope you enjoyed this video bros it
was a lot of fun to make while you're
watching this video I will be in New
Orleans on holiday me and my girlfriend
might say are celebrating our three-year
anniversary together I have videos
prepared for you bros but yeah just want
to let you know what's up that's pretty
much all for me thank you both so much
for watching and thank you for being a
bro as always here on Friday repair ba
we're gonna brofist
you ready alright one two three Brophy